>>> OKAY.
THAT WILL WORK.
THANKS, GUYS.
I'LL SEE YOU TONIGHT.
CAN YOU LEAVE MY MIC OPEN?
I'M GOING TO WORK ON SOME STUFF
BY MYSELF.
THANKS, GUYS.
♪ ALL EYES ON ME
MY EYES ON YOU ♪
>> HELLO.
>> WHAT UP?
>> OH.
IT'S YOU.
YOU'RE THAT ROADIE.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN MEANING TO
ASK.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
>> CHAD.
NICE TO PUT A NAME TO THAT
HANDSOME FACE.
>> WHO ARE YOU?
>> JENNIFER LOPEZ.
>> OKAY.
>> YEAH.
I SING HERE.
DID YOU HEAR ME SINGING?
>> YEAH.
>> DID YOU LIKE WHAT YOU HEARD?
>> NO.
>> THAT IS SO REFRESHING.
YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE YOUR
HONESTY.
SINCE WE'RE BEING HONEST, I HAVE
A LITTLE CONFESSION.
EVER SINCE I FIRST SAW YOU, I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET YOU OUT
OF MY -- CHAD!
CAN YOU NOT DO THAT NOW?
I'M TRYING TO TALK TO YOU.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> YOU KNOW, I SHOULDN'T HAVE
THESE FEELINGS FOR YOU, CHAD.
I JUST GOT ENGAGED.
>> CONGRATS.
>> AND I'M IN LOVE WITH ALEX.
>> WHO IS THAT?
>> RODRIGUEZ.
A-ROD.
>> HEH-HEH, ROD.
>> WHAT MORE COULD A GIRL WANT.
HE WAS A YANKEE.
>> HEH, YANK.
>> PART OF ME JUST WANT TO SAY
SCREW AND IT MAKE CRAZY LOVE TO
YOU ON THE STAGE RIGHT HERE.
>> SICK.
>> I CAN'T.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M SORRY, CHAD.
IS THIS MAKING YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> IT'S CRAZY, WE JUST MET BUT I
FEEL LIKE YOU SEE ME.
>> OKAY.
>> IT'S FUNNY, WHEN YOU'RE UP
HERE ON STAGE IN FRONT OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SCREAMING
YOUR NAME, IT'S EASY TO GET LOST
IN IT.
CHAD!
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> DID YOU FALL OFF THE STAGE
JUST TO MAKE ME LAUGH?
>> NO.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
FLIRT.
YOU KNOW, I'VE SEEN YOU,
WATCHING ME DANCE DURING MY
SHOW.
I'VE SEEN YOU LOOKING AT MY --
>> [ BLEEP ]
>> YOU'RE BAD, CHAD.
DO YOU WANT TO DANCE?
>> OKAY.
>> NO.
I MEAN SLOW DANCE.
OH, YOU'RE TOO MUCH.
COME HERE.
[ BURP ]
SOMEBODY HAD DORITOS.
>> JEN?
>> ALEX!
THIS IS MY NEW CHOREOGRAPHER.
>> NO, I'M NOT.
>> I HOPE YOU'RE HAPPY.
>> ALEX, WAIT.
>> CHAD, I HAVE TO GO AFTER HIM.
>> OKAY.
>> AND I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
LEAVE THE TOUR.
>> GOODBYE, CHAD.
>> GOODBYE, JELLO.